what's up guys my name is lauren
um and i'm here today to do a food swap
to help celebrate hispanic heritage
month
hispanic heritage month is important to
me because i'm
of hispanic descent my mom is panamanian
and i think it's very important for
people to know their heritage and to
celebrate it it's everything you know it
it's it runs in my blood it's in my
veins i was blessed to be able to visit
and just
was in awe of of the beauty that i saw
there the personality and culture that
you get and to know that this is
something that's part of me
is something that's that's very special
to me
[Music]
hi candace uh it's nice to officially
meet you i heard we're going to be doing
a little food swap here
it's good to meet you too i'm uh i'm
ready
[Music]
i am from jamaica as you can see i grew
up with obviously my own culture
and an appreciation for many other
cultures appreciation for the food
for their music for just anything that
makes them unique so the recipe that i
would be giving you
is a very important cultural special
dish to panama
it's the beef empanada it's a very
simple dish
i don't know what your cooking level is
and i didn't want you to mess this up so
i'm
starting off easy it's just fried dough
with meat in it
and i thought we would go with the beef
one because that's like kind of the
traditional og
your empanada i don't know if it's gonna
see my jamaican beef patty
but uh we're gonna see the beef patty is
also a simple dish
but you gotta make it with love the
ingredients is what makes it if you
don't have the good ingredients if you
don't have that seasoning
it's not it's not going to be there you
know right panama is
situated in the caribbean i feel like
we all are about the spices that's so
funny that you bring up spices candace
because i'm actually going to be
dropping the ingredients off at your
door
i'll make it a little a little easier on
you just a little easier that's so sweet
you know what i'm gonna do the same
thing for you
well candace i look forward to this
challenge i'm excited
get some empanadas get some beef patties
let's do this
i'm about to go to the grocery store
pick up these jamaican beef patty
ingredients for lauren
drop them off at her house and then see
what she's really working with
can she make these beef patties we will
[Music]
see
[Music]
whoa okay that was uh much more of an
adventure than i thought it was going to
be
but i finally got all the ingredients
for candace to make these bomb ass
uh beef empanadas got all my groceries
right there
so uh now i'm about to take him to her
the day has finally come uh i'm here
in my kitchen going to attempt the
jamaican beef patty
not gonna lie i'm kind of nervous here
you can see
are the ingredients candice has left me
with these don't seem so unfamiliar to
what i'm normally used to working with
so
hopefully this process won't be so
daunting
but anyway let's uh let's do this okay
so
about to make this dough in the food
processor
figure out this dough and cut in this
butter
and knead the mixture until it
looks like a breadcrumb consistency
it's dough now i don't have a rolling
pin
let's roll out these balls of dough but
i do have this water bottle
which i read it will work fine
here we go i'm going to roll out these
uh balls of dough
[Music]
so got the ground beef a pound of ground
beef next
we need two
tablespoons of soy sauce
you can get that in there juicy beef
juicy beef is important in this recipe
i got the beef cooked up a little disker
ready to put beef in almost i'm heating
up this oil in this pot it says i need
to put two and a half
inches of oil in the pot that's another
difference um so i don't know if it's
always baked jamaican meat pies or if
you are able to fry them just depending
on preference
i am asking candace to fry so hopefully
that's
going well for her i don't want to get
pop
this isn't as easy as i thought it was
um i'm clearly not
sealing the empanadas right because i'm
putting them in the pot
and they're bursting open so i have two
for lauren so far but i got a lot more
that i can try with
all of my patties are done i gotta say
it smells amazing i guess candace will
be the final judge i wasn't sure i could
do that
i did that i did that
i got four decent looking at your
i'm gonna go mouth him some lauren
outside let's go we have four good ones
okay four diesel this one's warm we both
tried we did
i have a lot of respect for jamaicans
and i have a lot of respect for
panamanian
me and candace have completed our
creations i made the beef patty
for her she made the beef empanada for
me um here's a little
little visual here you can see mckennis
tell me about your experience how was
making the beef empanada
i was quite cocky in the beginning i was
like oh this is gonna be easy this is
gonna be easy like
how hard is it to fry a pastry
i started frying them and then all of a
sudden they got really fat and they were
floating in the
wreath and it was like popping
everywhere and i was running from the
pot
but i enjoyed it and there are a lot of
similarities in making the
the patty for sure some of the
seasonings were similar
and some of the process is similar like
the end was definitely very different we
had a lot of similar seasonings but you
used them in the dough whereas i used
most of them in the meat
[Music]
now is the big taste test see how you
did candace i'll let the world see
here's a little visual
representation here we go
[Music]
it's good i mean i think for your first
time making these you named it you
nailed it
yes let me show the dish off
it's well sealed i bet you didn't have
any explosion problems with yours
those good haven't gotten to meet yet
though
i'll take it candace uptake not a bad
first try
oh thank you thank you thank you i think
it's always important no matter what
your cultural heritage is to know about
it um and to tell people how to express
it to be proud of who you are where you
come from definitely
got a lot more respect for cooking
different culture foods
always had respect for other cultures
but i just thought
that i can make anything it's fun and
it's great to
to know about your heritage and share
that history and that information
and also learn about the differences
because it's what makes us all unique
[Music]
you